[Musique]
Je suis Sue Ellen
Papa verra papa
cette fois des collations et manger des trucs tu te
caches Camilla ouais je te rencontre
je t'ai acheté quelque chose tu es plein de
merveilles ton plafond les gens pourquoi
un couteau te vole  parfois tu dois le
faire reculer tu caches quelqu'un
n'est-ce pas toi si quelqu'un le voyait
ils t'enlèveraient
et ils ne peuvent pas te dire ce qu'ils vont
faire [ __ ] les sous-sols de poulet maman
qu'est-ce que
tu as gardé  moi vivant écoute n'oublie jamais
ça
[Musique]
pour ça notre vie Lisa
si tes yeux pouvaient parler que diraient-ils
et il était une fois une fille
j'avais un ami qui vivait dans l'ombre
elle lui rappellerait comment le Soleil  sentait sur
sa peau
et ce que l'air ressentait à respirer
qu'il lui
rappelait qu'elle était toujours en vie bonne
nuit voleuse de livres